[MUSIC]
Hello and welcome to our conference call,
MBA Admissions Insights,
Being a Great Applicant.
Thank you for joining us.
My name is Ari Chasnoff.
I'm the communications manager
in the MBA Admissions Office.
I'm joined by my colleague, Lizabeth
Cutler, an Associate Director here.
>> Hi everybody.
>> So in the next 30 minutes, we'll be
talking about steps you can take to be
a great candidate for the Stanford
Graduate School of Business MBA program.
Then we'll answer some of the questions
you submitted in advance.
First let's discuss what
a great candidate even means.
>> Absolutely.
For us, that's about identifying people
who will be great students while they're
here on campus, and
who will have a meaningful and
positive impact wherever
they go once they graduate.
>> So what steps do you think people
can take to be a stronger candidate?
>> Here are some thoughts based on
interesting questions people have asked me
over the years.
There's a lot of different
ways people think about this.
One is focus more on being a great
candidate than creating a great
application.
Believe it or not,
we want to make the process as simple and
efficient as we can for you.
And we only ask for what we really
need to know to create a great class.
That said, I know the application process
takes so much of your time and energy.
Like anything you really want,
it takes hard work and
a lot of heart to be successful at it.
But sometimes I get the impression
when I'm talking to people
that someone's letting the application
process take over their life.
So if you spend every extra minute in
your year leading up to the application
studying for the GMAT or
the GRE, what aren't you doing?
So for example, given the choice between
taking on a great new project and
spending 24/7 on your application,
take on the project, it will give
your recommender more to talk about.
It will give you the kind of growth
opportunity that will help you become
a better student once you arrive.
>> Lizabeth, I've heard people ask, I've
got an exiting new job opportunity doing
something I've always wanted to do, but
everyone's telling me to stay in the same
job until after I get into school,
even though I'm bored.
>> Yep, I've heard that one too.
A great candidate for
us jumps on opportunities.
If you're ready and
excited about it, do it.
Don't do it to impress us, we're perfectly
happy that you stay in your current job
for whatever amount of time
that makes the most sense.
What I'm talking about is someone
who's ready for a change, but
using the application process
as an excuse not to do it, you
really want to get out and live your life,
and that makes you a great candidate.
Obviously, I want you to put the time and
effort in for a strong application,
what I'm talking about is
knowing when to draw the line.
What's the marginal benefit, that's a word
you learn maybe after becoming an MBA for
some of you,
of taking the GRE one more time, or
rewriting your essay one more time.
If you think at that point, you can
really improve either your score, or
your essay, or your application,
definitely spend that time.
But, if you reach that point where you
know, deep down, you've done your best,
and you're just worrying over it, move on.
You know,
we think you should follow your interests,
take the risk to try leading someone,
or leading something.
Learn from your successes and failures.
And apply that learning into
doing it better the next time.
Step up for challenges and
do an excellent job.
Those are the things that will show
up in your recommendations and
show up in who you are and get us excited.
>> So, your're saying,
do what you feel strongly about,
not just what people tell you will
help you get into business school.
>> Yes, absolutely.
Don't let anyone else
tell you what we want, or
that you should change your career
decisions which are so important and
so personal around
the application process.
You know yourself best.
If you want to know what we want,
come ask us.
That's why we travel around the world.
We do this webinar.
We answer the phones and
we post information on our website.
Always go to the source,
whether that's us or
another school, about what
the school is really looking for.
>> Mm-hm, great.
What else do you think could
help people be a good candidate?
>> Well, so one thing is we hope
you show us your best self.
Just make sure it's your self,
that it's really you being yourself
as opposed to what you think
we want you to sound like or
what other people are telling
you you should sound like.
And the other is, I think the best thing
you can do is really research the schools,
just like you're doing by
being on this call today.
Know why you want to come to Stanford.
What would you get from this experience?
And what makes it a good fit for you?
Because then you narrow down and
only apply to the schools
that are really good options for you, and
that'll show up in your application too.
>> So, if I am a great candidate
what else do I need to do
to actually demonstrate it?
Are there logistics of
submitting an application?
How are those important?
>> Yeah, I get the impression that
sometimes people spend too much time on
some things and miss others.
So here's some examples of
things people may miss.
One is just following instructions,
literally making sure you've read through
the instructions and follow them.
Another is to be aware of the deadlines.
Nothing that is submitted
after the deadline counts,
because we start reading
applications as soon as we get them.
So very often people will try to submit
information like another test score or
another recommendation or things like that
after the deadline and we don't accept it.
The other thing is to review
the entire application ahead of time so
you know what to expect.
So I think sometimes people will work on
the things they know about like I need to
get a letter of reference, but they won't
look at all the different sections of
the application and make sure they've
got everything that they need.
And so I think that's important.
And the last thought on that is to
make sure you're putting your best
foot forward and presenting yourself well.
But be true and
factual about your experience.
We do validate the information you
submit before you can become a student,
and we can rescind an offer if
you've misrepresented yourself.
So you do want to be careful about that.
>> There are all kinds of great students,
some inside the classroom,
some in extracurricular activities, or
in other contributions to their class and
the school.
There's really no one mold for
the perfect Stanford MBA student.
>> So true, and yet
they do have some things in common.
So let's quickly review
our evaluation criteria.
We'll just touch on this briefly since you
can learn more about this in our website.
>> Right so
the first one is intellectual vitality.
What are we looking for there Lizabeth?
>> The way I'd really encourage you
to think about this is Stanford is
a vibrant place.
It's a place to solve big problems and
take intellectual risks.
So, were looking someone that is
intellectually engage in whatever the one
or many topics are that
catch your attention.
>> Mm-hm.
Next for evaluation criteria is
demonstrated leadership potential.
What is the reason behind this one?
>> Well, we integrate graduates
students for increase ability to lead.
You've seen our model?
Change lives, change organizations,
and change the world.
It's the only way you can go out and
create change is if you can actually lead.
So we're both looking for
what skills you may have now and
how open you are to learning new ones.
Do you know what makes you a good leader?
Do you know what you
aren't good at at all?
It's okay if you don't have
much experience yet, but
a great candidate is at least
performing well at work and in school.
So they're likely to be in a position
to advance later in their career and
be able to lead.
>> Okay, well the third criteria we
consider is personal qualities and
contributions.
What do you mean by that?
>> This is the hardest one to explain.
There's no right or wrong answers to this,
it's a way of saying that we're interested
Interested in getting to know you.
We don't seek to put people in boxes and
don't have any quotas or anything.
So we look at each individual we consider
what they might gain from our program and
how they might contribute to the program.
>> Fantastic.
So now let's move on to answering
some questions from participants.
Thank you all for submitting so
many questions in advance.
So here's a question we received.
Many people talk about the importance
of distinguishing oneself.
>> From the majority in
the application process.
With regard to the essay questions,
what are some of the most common
mistakes made by the majority of
the applicants who are not admitted?
>> So the answer to this changes
year to year, of course.
I would say these days, the main one is
pushing your own agenda rather than just
answering the question we ask.
And frankly, even some of the people
we admit are doing this or
making this mistake.
So be really careful about the advice that
you take on essays even if it's someone
who got in, because you don't know if
the choices the made contributed to
them getting in or we're in obstacle
to our making a decision to admit them.
Really, the main thing for
you to do is take the time to reflect.
Read the question carefully.
Reflect on the true answer for
yourself and then spend the time trying to
articulate your answer rather than
thinking about anyone else and
distinguishing yourself from anyone else,
because you don't know who
else is applying and what they're saying
and that's just about impossible to do.
>> Second question, how would you evaluate
leadership potential in candidates,
whose professional rolls don't give
them opportunities to demonstrate it?
For example, in entry level positions or
positions where they don't need a team or
if they have a nontraditional background.
>> Yeah, so I think this is
an important question, because so
many of our candidates don't actually
have a leadership experience yet or
anything very formal.
It's not important, you don't have to
have work experience coming in and
you don't specifically have to
have leadership experience.
We're looking at the qualities
that you do have and
how they might contribute to
your effectiveness, as leader.
We're looking at your self-awareness,
because a good leader is able to learn
from situations around them and
adjust their behavior and actions.
Those are some of the ways I would start
looking at it and the other thing is
don't get tripped up thinking, we're only
looking for formal leadership experience.
It might be how you helped someone
next to you at work or something.
Many, many candidates are coming
from situations where they don't
have leadership opportunities yet.
>> Here's a question
about a candidate's GPA.
How can applicants confident in their
academic ability, but with a poor
undergraduate GPA demonstrate that their
intellectual capacity, discipline and
academic rigor is not limited to
their past academic performance?
So, we're not evaluating your GPA alone.
We're looking at your whole transcript.
We're looking at things you've done
since you finished undergraduate,
if you're not still a student.
So the question I'd ask you is what
leads you to believe that your,
let's see, your intellectual capacity,
your discipline and
rigor are different than your GPA shows?
What evidence can you
demonstrate to show that to us,
because that's what we're looking for.
We want the evidence that you
can succeed in the classroom and
that you contribute to your classmates.
So, that's what you want to think about.
>> Great.
So here's another question, what are the
best ways to engage as an applicant from
abroad to learn more about Stanford and
help Stanford get to know me?
>> Yeah, definitely a challenge.
So first of all,
I should make it very clear that we
don't expect you to come visit campus.
Anything you can do to learn about
us is great, but it's all for you,
so you can make a good
educated decision about us.
We're not a evaluating you based on
whether you've been involved with us or
attended anything.
That said, we are travelling literally
all over the world this summer and
take a look at our website.
See if we're coming somewhere near you or
close enough that you can get, so
you can meet some alumni and an officer in
person and really learn about the program.
We encourage you to do that and
then really, it's our website.
Dive in.
Ari's created amazing opportunities to
learn more about the program there,
like a day in the life and other things.
So, really focus on how you
can learn about Stanford.
You don't need to do anything separate in
order to help Stanford get to know you,
that's really the application.
So, the only way we're getting to know
candidates is through the application.
We don't expect people to do anything else
and to keep it as fair as possible, we're
evaluating candidates based, specifically
on their application not on any outside
factors like, whether you're coming
to campus, whether you know anybody.
None of that.
>> Fantastic.
Next question, does it matter which age or
point in life I'm in?
I have a vision and
direction I want to go in, but
I don't know what it's going to look like
in terms of job function or company.
>> This is a little harder to answer.
It doesn't matter what age or
point of life you're in to us,
it absolutely matters to you.
And so
the way it matters is you really want to
be thoughtful about why you
want to be in the program and
what you want to get out of it, and
be able to articulate that for us.
We're completely neutral about the where
you are part, it's more about where you
are and where you want to get and
how we can help you with that.
So if you have a general vision and
direction you want to go in,
then help us understand what that
direction is and why you think coming
here will help and why the MBA program,
specifically will help.
You definitely do not need to know
what exact job function or company.
You'll notice our essay two
question is more about Stanford,
it's not about your short and
long-term goals.
We don't ask that, because we know it's
going to change as soon as you get into
the application process and
certainly by the time you're a student.
And so we think that those longer
term visions and aspirations are more
likely to remain stable, and
that's what we're really interested in.
>> Well, here's an interesting question.
Someone is asking,
can you help us understand what
happens behind the scenes
after I submit my application?
>> Sure.
The key things that you need to know,
really are first of all, it's a real human
being that's reading your application.
It's not an algorithm.
I've had people who create algorithms for
a living not believe me,
but it is actually a fact.
So it's a real human being, it's me or
someone like me that's interested
in getting to know you.
Our readers are not faculty or students.
They're all paid staff and it's
a well-trained, well-calibrated group.
So, there's no randomness in here.
It's a professional, a group of
people reading your application.
We read it and we decide whether
you'll make it to interview.
And ultimately, whether those
interviewed will receive an offer.
>> Great.
The next question is how
do I strike a good balance
between communicating
the value I'd receive from
the program versus the value
I can contribute to peers?
>> Well, first of all,
that's a really great question.
I'm so glad you're even thinking about it.
I don't even know how to answer it,
because, I mean,
all you need to do is answer
the questions we asked and
that's not specifically
a question we'd ask.
So I think it's really,
especially up to you to focus on
what you are here to learn and
I think we'll pretty much assess what
value we think you can contribute.
It's not a question that we ask.
So but really,
great that you're thinking about it and
I hope that you're contributing to
the people around you wherever you are and
that also makes you a great candidate.
>> Great point.
So, the next question is about
the three evaluation criteria.
I know we recently discussed.
The GSB website talks about the importance
of three criteria, intellectual vitality,
demonstrated leadership potential,
personal qualities and contributions.
Where is the best place to communicate
these in the application process?
>> Yeah, again,
one thing doesn't correlate to another.
Those are the things that I keep in
mind as I'm evaluating every section of
the application.
So you might see more intellectual
vitality showing up in your transcript,
where we'll really looking
at what you studied and why.
But truthfully, it can come come
up anywhere in the application and
the same is true for
all the other criteria.
So they don't map to specific
locations in the application.
Really, they're things that shine through,
can shine through anywhere and
it really depends on you and your answers.
>> Fantastic.
Well, we got a high volume of
questions submitted in advance.
So we have about 13 minutes left.
So let's move on to some
additional questions.
Lizabeth, how would you recommend
a candidate reference personal or
professional relationships with
GSB alumni in their application?
Is there a special way
to go about doing that?
>> Well no, I guess I'm wondering
what's behind the question.
Is it that you're trying to demonstrate
that you know somebody here?
If that's the case, you don't need to.
And I don't necessarily even
encourage you to do so.
It's not a requirement.
It's not one of our criteria.
If theres something you learned,
if there's a reason, so for example,
if the GSB alums you've met
are the reason you're applying.
Or there's something about them
that stands out to you and
that's part of your decision process.
Then that could be relevant for
you to share, but otherwise,
I don't recommend you go out
of your way to do it at all.
I've had people ask me for a reference,
someone I know really well and
they thought well, as an alum it would
be really helpful to hear from you.
And I actually suggest they not waste
their time, so really focus on getting
references from people who know you well
and can speak to your performance at work.
And don't worry about the alumni factor.
>> Great, next question is
about reviewing one's essays.
What is the recommended process to review
and re-review your written statement?
How would you recommend going about that?
>> Yeah, so we have no recommendation,
it's totally your own process.
Some tips I've heard from
people are things like you can
give it to someone who knows
you really well and say hey,
if you read this essay,
would you know it was me?
Does it sound like me?
That's a way to make sure it's
really your authentic voice.
Another thing you can do is you can give
them the essay without the question on
it and ask them today,
what question do they think you answer.
That's a really great way to make
sure that you've answer the question.
What I be careful of is getting
too much feedback there or
having other people guide your process.
Anyone who starts to
tell you what we want,
what Stanford wants is
probably misguiding you.
So really focus on whether it sounds like
you and whether it answered the question.
And also to make sure
there's no lingo in there.
Have somebody who doesn't
know you're industry or
very much about your work,
take a look at it.
Because anyone should be able
to read it and understand it and
they shouldn't have to know
anything about business here in.
>> Great advice.
So the next question is, what if I live in
a country that has few opportunities for
minorities to show our skills?
How can I show that I'm a well qualified
applicant despite my lack of awards?
>> Well, first of all, this question makes
me a little sad and I'm really sorry that
anybody feels they don't have
opportunities to show their skills or
be their best.
And I certainly hope that coming here,
you'd have a very different experience.
We don't expect any specific awards,
so you don't need any to apply.
I think the most important
thing to understand is
that we have, people who are reading your
application have extensive experience.
We understand different
cultures around the world,
different cultures within the US.
Different cultures within
different organizations.
And those environments impact what
opportunities any one of us have.
And just like we understand
the transcripts and
grading systems are really
different all over the world.
So we're going to get some insight just
based on your application about that.
And we'll try to calibrate
our reading accordingly and
understand the context in
which you're operating.
And the other thing is sometimes it
comes through in the references.
Sometimes references give us an idea
about the context you're in and
what challenges you may
have in that context.
And that can be very useful as well.
>> Fantastic.
Here is another question
about a candidate's age.
This candidate says I'm
a 40 plus applicant.
Is there anything important for
a candidate in this age group to consider?
>> I don't think so.
So age isn't one of
the factors we consider,
what we're looking at is
what have you contributed?
How are you performing at
whatever level you're in?
So whether you're currently
a college senior or
you're two years out or five years out or
20 years out or whatever it is.
We want to see what you're actually
accomplishing and what you're impact is.
And we might expect slightly more impact
from somebody later in their career than
earlier in their career just because
they've had more opportunity
to create such impact.
That's really the only thing
that comes to mind for me,
I think people ask a lot
about the average age.
And they forget that that's really
a function not of our decision process but
of who applies and
people are typically applying.
And a different stage of their career, but
we're really excited to see anyone
at any stage of their career.
It's just one more kind of
diversity we can add to the class.
>> Great, so
here's a question from someone who has
already applied to the program and
is reapplying.
Any advice for re-applicants who
did not get interviewed in general?
Any general advice for re-applicants?
>> Sure, well first of all,
we welcome re-applicants.
I was talking to a student who told me it
was his fourth time that he got in and
he's having a great experience.
And the reality of it is that we only
have such a few number of seats in
the class for
all to the number of people applying.
And so we have to turn away
great candidates every year.
And we welcome you to come back and
take another try.
We will look at your application
fresh in the pool of
candidates that are applying
when you apply.
So we're not looking back at your previous
one and we don't want you too either.
We want you to really take it fresh.
An essay like what matters most to you and
why may not have changed.
It may have changed because
you've thought more deeply.
But you can certainly reuse an essay like
that, but you want fresh recommendations.
You really want to approach
the whole process fresh.
Don't let the fact that
you applied before and
had a negative outcome
dominate your process.
Just think of yourself as a new
applicant just like we would.
>> Great.
So the next question is relevant to
candidates who have experience in
the military.
How does the admissions committee consider
the role of mandatory military service?
Particularly if it
occurred before college?
And then, second part of that question
is what is the single most common
mistake that military applicants
make during the admissions process?
So we're aware that in certain countries
there's mandatory military service.
And we see obviously from every
applicant in that country.
Or in some countries every male
applicant in that country,
we'll see that mandatory service.
We are interested in what
you did during that time.
A lot of times it can be
a great opportunity to explore
your leadership skills.
And/or observe other people in leadership
roles in a different way than you do in
daily life.
But we don't look at it any differently
than any other application.
So we're still looking for
the same criteria in all candidates
regardless of what their specific path is.
And in terms of a single most common
mistake from military applicants,
I don't think there is one.
People are so different regardless of
what background they're coming from,
so I don't think there's
any one thing I see there.
We have lots of strong applicants,
nothing comes to mind.
>> Okay, I think we have time for
just a couple more questions.
So this next one is about
diversity here on campus.
The question is,
how does the GSB work to create an
intentionally diverse learning community?
How do applicants best demonstrate
their diverse backgrounds and
experiences in their application?
>> Paul, it's an exciting question it's
just one of the big challenges for us,
and an exciting one because we
really have the opportunity
to put together a class where people
get to know so much about each other.
And frankly, they learn lots of things
about each other that we didn't know in
the application process too.
And I think where people sometimes
get hung up here is that they very
narrowly define diversity.
And for us we look at it very broadly.
So every aspect of who
people are comes into play.
And yeah, there's no categories or
anything.
So how to demonstrate your background and
experience.
You have opportunity throughout
the application to just, again,
all you have to do is answer
the questions and it just shows up.
I think sometimes people are applying,
and they know other people are applying.
And they think,
how can I possibly distinguish myself?
We're all the same.
But the thing is, you're most likely to
be most like the people you know already.
They might be working in your company, in
your industry, they may be your friends,
but we're actually seeing a much bigger,
broader pool.
And so, we don't necessarily
see that as a challenge.
And this year in our More About You
section there's actually an opportunity to
specifically share how you
think your background or
your perspective has had
an impact on your experiences.
So that's another place as well.
>> Great point.
So, let's look at the last question
that we've taken this session.
Elizabeth, are students that apply for
deferred admission evaluated separately or
differently from those applying for
direct enrollment?
>> No, they're not.
That said, so
basically all candidates are reviewed
together in the round in which they apply.
But the one difference is that obviously
we have a set number of spots for
next years' class, and so
as we get to round three,
we have much fewer seats to offer,
it gets more competitive.
But for deferred admission,
we don't have that limitation, and so for
college seniors, anybody applying
that qualifies to deferred admission,
you can actually apply and In round three,
because it's not going to be more
competitive then, it'll be about
the same throughout the rounds.
That's about it.
The application process and
the evaluation process are identical.
>> Great.
Well, we're almost out of time.
If you didn't get your
question answered today,
feel free to contact our office by email.
Now, or phoned to ask your question.
Before we go, Elizabeth, any last word for
our listeners today in terms of
how to be a great applicant?
>> Sure, my one last thought is that one
thing our students really have in common
is that they all applied.
You can't change the world if you
aren't willing to fight the odds.
>> Thanks, Elizabeth.
And thanks to you all for joining us.
There is one more MBA admissions
insights conference call coming up.
It's called, considering a joint or
dual degree.
And it's on August 31st.
So if you're considering doing a joint or
dual degree.
Try to join us for that one.
You can register for it on our website.
An audio recording of all of our
conference calls including the one today
will be posted on our website
in the next few weeks.
You can already find two up there.
The current application is now
available through our website.
There are three application deadlines,
September 21st,
January 10th and April 5th.
There are lots of ways to learn
more about our program and
the admission process on our website.
You'll find videos of past webinars and
a calendar of on and off campus events.
We look forward to
reading your application.
Enjoy the rest of your day and good bye.
Thank you.
>> Bye everybody.